alright so we just got back from
spider-man into the spider-verse I feel
like we're gonna have some unpopular
opinions here but I think this kind of
fire the course without some spider-man
movies yeah if someone can explain to me
why the one with spider pig or ham
Parker Peter porker do you I can't
remember why that one is probably my
favorite spider-man I love it I love my
dad slinging shit out of this movie and
I might be my favorite I really might be
yeah what happened here I don't get
where this series as a franchise what's
so wrong and how is this the trackpad
this that this is the one that feels
like it got mostly everything right but
it got everything right in a completely
new unique crazy way that funny enough
what Sony usually does is it throws too
much shit at you and this kind of does
it yells - but understand captained by
people who know what they're doing yeah
and like really show me a problem is
always that they'll get somebody with
some talent and then they'll be like
here you need to put venom in this here
you need to put this in this here you
need this we need this we need this so
that we can set up our the franchise and
do this and these poor people who may
have talent are basically being under
minded by the studio the whole way
through it happened to Sam Raimi I think
it happened to Marc Webb like I don't
musta haven't with the sea yeah I don't
I don't think Marc Webb is like an awful
director you know and so now finally
like we've got kind of two in a row now
where Sony it seems as backed off and
just literally it seems like they prop
they must they must have done some shit
with venom I was gonna say it's the same
year venom came out I'm not talking
about venom I'm talking about homecoming
oh but that's a good point I forgot what
I forgot about venom not Sony that's
Disney now I didn't I cap some sort of
deal with each other and make that oh
did they I don't
I don't know correct us in the comments
I forgot if it was something where they
were like working together because maybe
they just say well maybe that's why
maybe this but I finally feel like okay
well if they didn't they have anything
to do with homecoming then and then in
this case this is the first one where it
feels like there's so much shit in this
movie but I feel like the studio just
backed off and was like well if you
think this is gonna work like this is
what the smooth ER are they either
completely backed off and let weird be
weird cuz it's like Phil Lord and Chris
Miller and stuff like that guys who did
the lego movie and were already kicked
off of another movie because it was too
weird we're so low now I'm really
wishing I do what I know that might not
have been good I live with them in
church but it would have been more
interesting this is the first outside of
Marvel where I actually they set up this
cinematic universe very cleverly and a
lot more times even you know I'm like
shit I want to see a movie at every
single one of these characters like
every one of them they set up at the end
this is what drives me nuts cuz like
homecoming was I thought a very good
movie it was a lot of fun you know
Holland was a great the best high school
Peter Parker I've ever seen
and the definitely Michael Keaton was
the best villain the series had ever
seen and honestly Michael Keaton was the
best thing in the movie it was also a
movie about nothing like that it was
literally about nothing I had no
understanding of what the park robbed it
was all about spider-man trying to
impress Iron Man which is what
spider-man's about a start they
mentioned very briefly Uncle Ben
somewhere they tell me it's in there but
that was apparently the focus of Goofy
and I missed that there's a lot of
people have pointed out that no no is
about Oh could you tell wasn't in there
at all could you tell me that one time
uncle man you got just dropped in a
throwaway line yeah that's what it's all
about
they've gotta since it's all Uncle Ben
base like we explain the home they have
this crap where he's trying to like
connect with his family and his father
and he's got the
or depressing Ironman let the defense
man we'll get to there you saying that
wasn't the defenders by Randall was no
I'm spider-man I'm Slade we're gonna be
a popular is a very entertaining movie
that was also the Seinfeld of superhero
movies it was a show about nothing yeah
and just like Seinfeld is very hilarious
it's not like you come out of Seinfeld
like oh the deep meaning of no it's a
show about nothing and that was
homecoming now what bothers me is
particularly the Uncle Ben things we buy
well listen you can't waste time talking
about Uncle Ben again because you just
it's been done to death like we can't we
just can't meanwhile this one hip for
freaking origin stories tucked into it
and they deliver they all acknowledge
they're very similar all four of them I
swear didn't take up more than five
minutes of shut-eye one and all of them
and it gave me a keen insight into their
character the four characters five
minutes and I knew more about them than
I ever did about Peter Parker and
homecoming so don't tell me that now
here's something here's something you
should make very clear I think going
into that I think this is very important
spider pigs origin story is talk Nicolas
Cage is one of the spider anyway I have
not read any I mean I know Lily nothing
about Miles Morales to you if you read
any of the comics or anything like that
uh like just the first few okay I know
nothing about spider-gwen except again
she's from a paranoid I only know of a
that's nowhere I only know of her I have
no I didn't even know there was a spider
pig I'm still wondering if there's a
Simon noir I'm hoping there's a spider
oh my god I want to read I never knew
about that you know you should check
that what does exactly what's supposed
to do but watch me it wants me makes me
want to see more and it makes me if you
wanna go read the cow fight not but but
we we are not going into this being like
oh yeah they got they got miles right
they nailed it I don't know I have no
idea what the character you want to know
a funny thing about it the really funny
thing about it is so the last time I
read any spider-man see
seriously was like 1993 and I have not
really touched much in the way of
spider-man since then and I can tell you
that this got adult Peter Parker records
we the 80s there's finally a spider-man
it's not the fourth iteration of some
high schooler we get to see whether as
an adult
miles is miles is but not a Parker
correct they finally got a spider
kitchen with this so that's what this
movie managed to do at the other one it
gave us both we got both a young
spider-man and a mess and it gave older
that's spider boy and spider-man to give
us older Peter Parker adult problems
like tough adult problems and you see
him actually go through an arc as well
almost everybody like he goes through an
arc Myles absolutely goes through an arc
his parents go through an arc like you
can argue that maybe saw the father on
the island see the father
oh yeah but I mean so the spider-gwen
and like noir spider-man and spider
pigley like they don't go through huge
arts but freaking penny Parker's she's
got a little mini are yeah I was like
tearing up at the end I'm like Oh miss
like anime Spider Girl like basically
has it's this this movie looks gorgeous
I love the hell out of this art stuff
and then I saw the trailer I got really
excited for it um the the characters are
all really fleshed out even though the
throwing a lot at you they are so
entertaining and so funny and just is so
enjoyable to listen to and to see and
swing around it is just cool to see a
ton of spider people swinging around
it's like never dawned on me like yeah
how you always see one Peter Parker and
said but not to see like five of us
swinging around and doing flips and
jumps and fighting all these bad guys
just like fever yeah that is cool right
wasn't that be cool what makes it work
and what makes it so much cooler is you
give a shit about the characters yeah
like oh my god I cared about each and
every last one of them even spider pig
he was trying you know it i I just I
don't get it I can't wrap my head around
us that now near when did that film like
to come
so more than 15 years after Raimi's
spider-man came out I feel like they
finally kind of nailed it somehow and
I'm like and it's the one with a talking
spider pagan well and it's it's one that
is so you know it's super super
self-aware it has a lot of in jump it
obviously has everything we should hate
you know what else but no else it does
have pathos which is something
homecoming I didn't have it had next to
no pathos except for the one scene where
he's like great then like it's fine but
like that that was just it there was no
path that was on the restaurant we
really wanted to impress Iron Man we
want to impress Iron Man I keep
forgetting Ben was maybe mentioned so
they nailed it I mean I'm sorry so leave
the comment so I did the Disney temper
like how can you which is why in my
opinion um I think I think this movie is
probably not gay I think I'll do okay at
the box office
I don't know if many people are gonna
like I think that'd be so weird this is
the thing it's gonna be way too we this
is the only one that is thought outside
of the box like really unique like this
I'm sorry really it's totally unique
that was still spider none of them have
really been unique since Raimi's film
like that was the only way and that was
unique because it was the first to try
you know and since then none of them
have really been unique they have been
like they they're either sucked or in
the case of homecoming they're very well
executed but there's nothing really
challenging about them I was saying with
I when talking about homecoming
the Raimi films I mean I said before I'm
not the biggest fan oh but that's
Richard Donner Superman yeah it's camp
and that's fine that they're fine for
what they are but a doll right I have a
motion and pants not even though it's
camp just like Donna there's a Superman
but on top of that uh it didn't play it
safe it did things really weird
yes well those not always successfully
but it went for no correct
but I think this movie does the same not
always successfully but it goes for
broke
yes I give people credit when they take
a risk on something you know because
it's your gonna work it's your gonna
really work or it's not gonna work and a
lot of times this but in the rain
experiments I didn't feel work piles
like okay I I'm glad you did that
because then you get something like
homecoming which is good and charming
and a lot of fun but like you said it's
about nothing it's instantly homecoming
I actually don't know it I had a blast
I've seen it three times but they saw
most recently again because everybody
kept trying to tell me your opinion will
change yeah yeah so I watch it again
recently and I'm just like no I still
don't get better but it is funnier but
and it's a great comedy but it's really
not about anything
yeah this has legit emotional moments in
it fucked uh yeah surprisingly no I'm
just like well I'm getting all like
choked up over something like this is
really well handled yeah and good voice
acting too man out of everybody in this
there's a lot of scenes with miles
particularly horseplay miles if there's
one scene where he's being choked by
somebody we find out later it is calves
this big character it's like you think
just talking joke like you know please
don't do it it's like whoa that's a
shilling ya know there's a lot of
chillin scenes in this that I'm just it
so surprises me because it's the
complaint about Marvel movies is that
whether to funny they're too funny and
therefore you can't take it seriously
and like this was business like this was
one well I mean there's a lot of times
it's a DC fan boy will say that but I
hear other people even Marvel fans
sometimes like yeah maybe they don't
always have to have jokes away this one
like the powerful emotional stuff was so
good that the the jokes didn't detract
too much but if I there looks just fun
yeah if I have one like I've got a
couple minor complaints about the movie
I one I think is I like look at
something like hand Parker or whatever
and like this this talking spider pig
and the movie does these big emotional
moments
so good that way you see the pic and
then we've got the spider pig and I'm
like man did they even really need to
did they need him like an Diana penny
Parker's and that one's like so the art
style and Penny Parker is like way more
kawaii anime okay no it's but it's it's
anime but like the version that I
remember seeing was a little more like
standard kind of Ghibli anime like a
little more realistic but definitely
anime still like this is very like don't
ye over-the-top sort of like manga style
and so even that one I thought she was
great too but when it kind of cuts to
them like because like no more
spider-man and spite of what I can I can
take like a little more seriously like
it can take both of them pretty
seriously but when it cuts to those two
in these big emotional moments I'm like
you know this movie is so damn good I
almost wish they didn't have to throw
those two things in there like maybe
they just weren't fully confident like
now we got to go for program it's just
so good that I'm like yeah it's a little
hard there's one scene I had a similar
reaction I mean if they pulled it out
just enough cuz they framed it right by
where is it the wild thing about bits
one there's one scene where spider may
have a they want miles to stay behind if
Peter Parker's gonna go as I know it's
too dangerous too so he weds into a
chair and puts Webb on his mouth I me
and I'm gonna come like a mummy's cover
into this this chair and then like his
dad comes by and there's this big
emotional scene this fireman outfit with
the wit just wrapped in this webbing
can't even talk and you're supposed to
get like oh he's really giving this big
heart and I'm like if they do it like
this is it this isn't gonna work but
they thankfully got tighter on his face
and his eyes I'm like okay that's good
but there's the split side where I'm
like maybe this isn't gonna work you
know and it was pretty goofy and I also
have two questions motivation cuz like
if I was going to get about it I really
like duct-taped to a chair like I'd be
like like I'd be like trying to make
noise or something like get me out of
here like nobody else I mean I guess
because he's in the spider suit but
nobody else oh yeah he doesn't want the
father to know but it just
but yeah he said there but you know what
makes that seem work is it one like
father's having emotional moment to
that's every parent's dream to be able
to talk to your teenage son without time
talking back but three it it's the exact
same freaking scene and they do it twice
in this movie that they did in
homecoming with like the lifting up cuz
I got a channel in all my like courage
to escape or whatever or remember what
it's about all you know why he's doing
it here like the speeches dad gave and
everything it's like okay I get what's
flowing in this character's head so
something else I have to pull a scene
from the comics or be like well we're
gonna shove this piece of wall up but
it's gonna be this big important you've
got why it was important because the
movie set everything up to tell you why
this was important to this character
white this is the moment that he's gonna
come into his own and he he did it again
to in the in there in like the whole
climax like you know when is his dad's
basically looking on and it's like Oh
everything's getting rough and he's
gotta like you know fight back and
that's like it's the exact same scene as
homecoming I'm like wow it shows you how
much context makes a scene because when
you know what's motivating the character
the scene is so much better and it's way
goofier in this movie like lifting a
wall in homecoming and this one he's
just spider webs to a chair and it's
ridiculous but you know what's going on
in his head and that's what's more
important you know in that scene with
the father you think he's gonna kind of
say one thing he says it's like and in a
way he does you know but he doesn't say
the exact words I mean he's gonna go and
say like if somebody has passed which is
something we already know even he
already knows uh but instead he kind of
like says don't don't make the same or
be who you want instead which is kind of
like his way of like he was about to say
what happened to this character but he's
like he changes it to get out what he
really wants to say which is you know
did it be be you you know and follow
your path and stop you know which is we
is waiting for you know the father say
and it's just so good I mean it's just
well it's so strong it's works perfectly
executed because again when you get down
to it it's a lot of your standard like
Disney shit like you don't find yourself
but fuck but you have
fill it up with the other character yeah
and as you have is an you know the
connection his pre spider-man dreams to
kind of be an artist and this and that
and it's definitely yeah and you see how
he just goes down this rabbit hole to
becoming spider-man and it's not just
because oh I got Tony Stark Envy know he
promised spider-man himself he would do
this and some else I like last promise I
fought back after this movie was done I
thought back to the Power Ranger movie
that came out recently where they did
kind of the risky thing of not having
them be in the Power Rangers Sue's doing
all the Power Ranger stuff until vm
they're saving it up and it might pay it
in quite work and this one kind of did
the same thing where he's not in the
black suit he's not doing all the you
know hardcore spider-man stuff phase
known for but the reason it works here
is not only the building it up not only
begin the character down but you have a
ton of other spider-man's doing so
entertaining is great watching him
awareness grew up and then stir up
sometimes human different personalities
him in that suit with his like wide eyes
it makes him way more vulnerable you're
really terrified for him you're like
yeah this is a kid like and him and just
the silly kind of spider-man like
pajamas like I honestly figure you
empathize with him way more earlier on
and then by the time he gets into the
actual suit you're like okay well now
he's badass now you know it really did a
good job of like yeah like I really
empathize with this honestly if I were
like 12 years old like I would love this
movie to death
cuz I really I really never see like the
mindset of kids who like you know like
comic books is about yeah empowering
kids and like but it's not just well
empowering how you're badass now like
you have to go through a lot of shit to
get there and what I like it looked yeah
I mean we always say a movie which
exactly like Colin's character really
yeah that's just mostly I'm already kind
of spider-man and I'm like I mean I
guess that's one way to do it because
they just got so sick of telling an
origin story but it's like we're still
missing a key piece of the puzzle yeah
and then the the other one like to both
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
they're like kind of - old Maguire sells
it way more as the high school student
but even then I still like I don't know
there's something about Miles Morales
particularly this movie that's also the
power of animation where it's like yeah
I fear
yeah this is definitely an egg McGuire
looks young but I don't like it this is
don't like this I I don't know you've
got a time all right he's too dopey I
want a root for him I don't want the
dork
I want to root for spider-man I know
he's a dork
bye don't want laugh at him the whole
time now you got one because we gotta
yeah spider-man and he's also a complete
and total schlub and yet I still think
he's the best spider and I've seen them
Thanks yeah well that's why I like
Garfield a little bit more cuz I felt
like well okay I get these not the geeky
Peter Parker and that boy Warren and
they Lisp and more but but yeah like
don't know no but it's like okay but
he's yeah I hear well I want to get
behind this guy I want like I'm swinging
around I don't want to be Tobey Maguire
Garfield okay so BtoB the Flyers I'm
spider-man - or amazing spider-man - is
that Garfield's really good in it and
he's a great Peter Parker and so's a
movie yeah and she's a great great Gwen
Stacy the movie blows now in the first
amazing spider-man he's an awful Peter
Parker because I don't believe he's in
high school for a second he looks like
he's 25 looks like the age of the
spider-man in this movie you know that
Peter Parker so but that's the tragedy
of and I did love Garfield particularly
in the second movie because I'm like
this is the adult spider-man I wanted
and now we finally get him and he's
surprisingly really schlubby and yeah we
made that work because if the halfway
point he goes through his own arc he's
like alright I gotta get back when I saw
and he sells it it's like because I saw
I saw the teaser for this movie I got
really excited like oh my god this is
different this is cool it looks amazing
I'm so excited that I saw the second
trailer where I shows fluffy Peter Park
I'm like oh no does Maki I saw the third
trailer and I went okay this my dad you
want to know it you won't know what's
funny I only saw the first trailer I
didn't see the next - so sitting there
in the movie when I found out that I'm
like oh this is schlubby
alternate-dimension spider-man I had
that reaction in real time I was like
and then like as it went on I'm like
okay like he's not my Peter Parker
[Laughter]
now I need to bring entitled Star Wars I
just feel like if anyone really likes
this Peter Parker but like I don't know
I guess it is an alternate-dimension but
at the same time that is kind of I don't
even know this is nobody's legit sure is
that because it's an alternate dimension
he can kind of be this way but even then
I didn't know if I was gonna like that
they gave him that again a one-minute
origin story where I knew everything
about him now now yeah like okay I can
see where he came from and why you
slubby and he did the hard times were
the other Parker but he didn't and but
what surprised me is not only how much I
was laughing at him and with him he was
legit really entertaining and then how
much I was feeling sorry for him but by
the end I was really like okay cool
you go Peter Parker like that that's
actually legit cool he seems to really
go through this arc that I got behind
him that was really my biggest concern
was I'm like that people he was invested
in all of these characters and there's
like five of those like five Spider Men
and you know women or you know eggs yeah
animals things I was invest in all of
them and yet I was still invested the
most in Miles Morales yeah there's
there's like bit where they sort of
steer away at her a little bit I was
like you know I want more miles and then
they bring it back to him like
immediately at the point where I got a
lot more miles they bring it back to
then like that was a problem I had with
homecoming I'm really invested in the
villain and I think Tom Hollands a
really funny guy but I'm not really
invested in his character speaking of
which we should talk the villain is the
one weak thing of this movie yeah and
he's not bad but it's kingpin and he
looks like grew from Despicable Me
that's the only way I can describe him
he's like just get away from Chicken
Little and he looks like that mixed with
the bodyguard it's from Triplets of
Belleville tell me what that's it's
character design like that's what he's
supposed to think in the comments
it's not like this you know that's a
weird this is actually the first kingpin
I've ever seen
by that issues with I've seen many
different King die I loved him in the
cartoon actually even liked him in the
Ben Affleck there's a Ben Affleck there
ya know I love the mirrors in front of
her no no no but Ben Affleck daredevil
oh the app oh yeah oh don't kid thing
Michael Clark okay Michael yeah Raymond
I even so he wouldn't be refuted no I
mean very different but I love that like
the kingpins one of the things that like
everyone usually gets perfect and this
is the only one where I'm like yeah he
does have a purpose for doing everything
it does add a little dimension buddies
just kind of an accent yeah cute display
yeah she sounds a trump yeah you despite
a man you fired
oh yeah I I didn't know what they were
doing with that well and his design is
weird and then they tried to give him
this backstory which I'm totally behind
it I was a really good back story again
kind of it's like the one issue with the
film didn't you just want more I wanted
more of that backstory why did Laura if
I have a small issue with a film and
like this to me is a sign of a good
movie when you want more what boy yeah I
want a more of his backstory and the
film's like two hours long hands like a
bajillion could have added 15 minutes to
this film and I would have been fine
yeah like totally fine no I want a
little more with him I'd say my only
other minor complaint is I watch a lot
of anime I'm used to a low frame rate
but there are points in this one where
the frame rate got so low I was getting
a little like headachy where I'm just a
that's bothered me so much like kind of
flashing and I'm like there's too many
pieces of missing information like I
wanted more frames of animation well why
bother me is that leave once in a while
when out-of-focus 3d effect
I don't it's fine once or twice and they
don't do it too much they just which
makes it look like you're watching half
of a 3d movie with the 3d glasses off
that's the only way good place all right
this stuff that's out of focus and
that's very clever it is clever I again
like this is a case where it's like I
appreciate them trying to think out of
the box
particularly because I'm just I get the
impression some of these decisions might
have
budgetary oh you and I had a
disagreement out is really amazing
looking no it's amazing look oscillation
oh it's an amazing looking movie but I
can see where corners were cut to get
you this look and it's very pretty like
the slowed the slow the scene in the
graveyard was gorgeous hell of a sunlit
garden yeah there's a ton of gorgeous
scenes um but it's not a lot of frames
of animation and that's why I think a
lot of the slower scenes those come more
anime based scenes work some of the
faster action sequences are very well
put together I'm not complaining they're
not it's just it's like there's just
little frames of animation missing like
it's a very low frame rate and my eyes
does that's intentional i I don't know I
don't like what ever they even do the
high five and stuff like that like it's
never blurred like nation would do bc
ever even ranch no because it's in the
movie but is it intentional it's like we
want this to be an artistic decision
we're going to cut the frame rate down
enough timing it works we don't have a
lot of money we want this to look super
good how do we cut costs well lower the
frame rate like I I don't even think I
think it was but you know this also
remind me a lot of I have no idea but
for what they had to work with I think
this is a stunning looking movie yeah
and you know what it reminds me of
reminds me of Odyssey there might be a
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world like fully
realized
which is why cuz I hate that that's the
only movie that right did that I didn't
like a lot like that the the style is
pretty cool and I thought I was gonna
hate the style in that movie but my not
you can't want me over but it's one of
those things where I'm like when I saw
this I'm like okay that was put here
it's pushed all the way and I think
thought I was gonna hate the word
bubbles at first and then as I figured
out what they were doing I'm like
alright no it's actually really funny it
actually accents the comedy yeah that's
the thing everything all the additions
that they had it's kind of like the new
Ninja Turtle cartoon that came out like
you know the action and the style and
everything
as long as I still had a good focus and
character and story which they did it
just accented everything and didn't
distract it didn't become the star it
just accented what everybody was going
through and that's what it's supposed to
do that's what the style of a movie is
supposed to do
um and in in my opinion like I said I
mean in a world where venom was a big
box office hit and homecoming is seen as
the definitive spider-man movie I'm
assuming this is right with that but I
mean the definitive Spence
this is the one that got it right
they're not gonna top it there's got it
right
spider-man movie it's the most
entertaining spider-man movie but that
doesn't make it definitive or best
that's kind what I thought too I thought
most entertaining until this one oh this
one I felt more yeah maile blew it out
of the water um but I I just think for a
lot of people the animation is gonna be
too distracting too weird the actions
probably gonna be too fast and the ideas
are gonna be too strange and I I think
at the very least this is gonna get a
real cult following at the at the bare
minimum I own a scenario it'll be a big
hit and I wanted a lot more these movies
which I want to see this is the first
time I'm excited for cinematic universe
and a Spider Man see quite never been
excited for a spider-man clip where I'm
like I'm probably gonna be sitting
through the next homecoming film
thinking I'll find it all but what's
gonna go on in the spider-verse like
yeah that's the one I'm really looking
forward to now and I can't wait for
another one
ya know so uh I mean it's it's one of
those things I think if you see the
trailer and you're like oh I don't like
that I think it's fair to say most of it
but we know if you look you like that
looks pretty cool and I'm really open to
this weird idea of these other spider
people coming in and them interacting
and seeing of it you know but to a lot
of people I get there might be one no
there might be people are like look I
just want miles of story just dive into
miles of story and nothing else and it's
like well they're enough it did coming
didn't even do with Peter Park no no no
but I mean like okay oh yeah I've ever
read the comic I'm just going to assume
that the miles company doesn't have a
bunch of our characters killer spider
characters coming and it focuses more on
different details in his life and stuff
like that where this one it definitely
does focus on that's the main focus but
there's also all these are spider people
that come in that are not usually a part
of that comic and you know it's like if
they did the first
Batman but had like you know did the
Adam West Batman coming in and let go
Batman coming it's like that'd be great
if they did well but I also would want
to see a Batman movie you know I've been
never been done before
so I can see somebody's saying like I
just want my miles movie and that that's
kind of it is kind of sad that we've had
three iterations of spider-man and when
we finally get to Miles Morales it's the
one with the cartoon pick it out like we
couldn't do it an actual serious movie
miles around it's like we had it and I'm
not bad-mouthing this before it is
movies amazing but but let's be a busy
show it really tells me like cuz this is
what I thought when they when they
announced homecoming and they're just
like we're to take him back to high
school again these would be really
really young and I just remember sitting
there going I'm like why don't you just
do like Miles Morales then why are we
going through Peter Parker 3.0 now
honestly in those movies I think you
should do like what they do with Peter
Parker here you could just make him an
adult or like what they did the first
Batman just like you know making that
Dolph give him the backstory you know
that be PI at least be something kind of
difference to the high school thing
again and granted this is you know a
high school thing again but it's a
different character I mean he's
definitely not Peter Parker he's a very
different charming funny interesting
character that like watching Anna Watson
see what happened he is so I just can't
believe they finally got it right where
I'm just like where's the eighties
spider-man I grew up with being the
adult Parker that was like wisecracking
and pretty funny and like and like they
finally got it I just I still can't
believe that I just saw that because I
thought I was not gonna see it and this
you know you know get kind of schlubby
but even then early on yeah the real one
he needs they're practically the same
guy it's just the other one had a more
schlubby ER life leading up to that but
they're pretty much the same they had
this in character design pretty much now
here's my question cuz again I we
haven't kept up too much with like the
newer spider-man's or anything so this
Peter B Parker that's the name of this
other one that has the gun as things go
wrong and as
you know he's kind of falling apart and
everything um I don't read the comics oh
hey is he a thing in the comics and B
you see the one who so whatever that I
was here
gee that would be amazing if that's what
that would be like the one else in
everybody's memory was yeah now it can't
it's probably technically a campy but it
would be amazing if like they actually
like did they like tried to connect it
and just like in a slightly different
way but um no I thought like that's like
I never wanna get into spoiler territory
yeah you can just keep it oh I'll keep
it vague there's just a lot of like
heart-tugging moments and then of course
Stan Lee has a cameo oh that was them
that was rough like it it's funny
because it's played for comedy at the
end of it
cuz they didn't know he was gonna die
before no here's what bugs me okay I
won't say what he says cuz he pops up
but you remember the first thing he says
in that cameo mm-hmm well if they just
stopped there and had nothing I hear
they haven't like wouldn't have been
amazing it that it could only think he
said hey could I would have been the
last yeah that would have been a
last-minute cosplay like so plays it up
for comedy at the end like I do like a
joke and though but it's but it's both
like it's it's a meaning the credit they
have and I am late because it's Stanley
and then but it plays up for a joke at
the end because they didn't know at that
point then this was gonna happen this
was like any other Stan Lee cameo but it
was really rough watching this just like
Oh biggest nitpicking but if then when
you see the movie you see I was talking
about the first thing he says if they
just cut at that moment I would just
died of tear I would have been like oh
but they they go for the lap and I'm
sure that's what was in the original
movie I did - fair enough in fact maybe
that's part of it it's like oh just keep
it happy to keep it cheerful but like
yeah just like they just cut it the
first line he said I just love them like
I'll say you know what just put a yellow
sign that says spoilers down yeah I knew
that the movie was really working for me
because they they kill off
the Parker in the Morales universe and
then it was really affecting to see like
you know
Morales promised Peter like oh I'll do
it I'll destroy this this thing they did
burn Superman funeral vendor Superman
movies yeah and that's the thing like
that's okay that's pathos it's not you
know it's different from Uncle Ben dying
and we don't know like he had kind of a
spider-man Envy but it wasn't just like
you know he also had dreams of becoming
an artist and so it's like he takes it
upon himself to do this but it was this
this one scene where it's just like
watching the TV and it's like a spoof of
CNN but a really convincing looking
spoof and it just says spider-man really
named Peter Parker dead at age 26 I'm
just like Jesus that just like everyone
checking their phone and like it's
really real my breath away I was just
like and then the way they're talking
the news like it turns out he was really
Peter Parker of former grad student and
I'm just like all the stuff left on the
gray yeah great yeah and then when they
go to Aunt May's place and like she no
no more fans and and like this and then
and she sees her you know yeah all the
way alive again I mean yeah there are a
lot of scenes I'm like wow this is
really getting to me like this is rough
particularly for something that looked
like you know Raju's gonna be some light
hearted kind of kids thing and then in
the same vein like so it's revealed so
his uncle Morales his uncle is one of
the villains which you didn't figure
that out like no I can I saw him kind of
dumb cuz he literally has only one other
scene yeah but to be seen and it's like
well of course I wasn't thinking it
there but the second Morales is back at
his uncle's place and you just see the
guys talking from the outside but when
he's right looks like he's ready to kill
my house on the rooftop there I was just
like Jesus yeah I know that he puts the
mask over his face I'm like is this a
fucking execute that's what I thought
he's gonna do and then he puts it down
to Mike huh
thank Christ but it's like I got really
fucking emotionally invested and wrapped
up in the movie
ya know it's um yeah I'm trying to think
was there anything and then like Peter
at the end like what the flower is going
back to Mary J and I was like oh yeah
penny Parker of losing the robot I'm
just like no I'm just like there were so
many characters where I'm like I'm so
way more invested in this than in any
spider-man movie in years
yeah I was gonna say I'm trying to even
think like the only time if only this
hand a villain as good as the vulture in
homecoming this would have been a
hundred percent for me yeah I'm trying
to think like in the other movies like
in terms of like legit really emotional
I can think like when they were passing
him down on the train yeah there was
nothing in the marquel you know a man
coming to life I thought was a really
beautiful emotional see it's okay that's
a good scene tucked in that crappy movie
but yeah I really liked Amazing
Spiderman by I mean there's no oh feels
you know ya know this because we've seen
all this had the pathos that comic books
need yeah like you can be funny as hell
this movies funny as hell but you need
that pathos buried deep down in there
somewhere
yeah Marvel movies have them and they do
well yeah they do yeah like I'm not
dumping a little Marvel movies I'm just
saying like this has been a Spider Man
problem yeah or it just they try too
much at the last second to inject it
when without the context you don't care
like when like what does an uncle dies I
am more feeling for that as he like
stands over his uncle he's like no man I
let you down I had more feeling for that
than when Gwen Stacy died an amazing
spider-man 2 because they pull that out
of their ass get robbed it's not Iron
Man if that wasn't a guy Iron Man I'm
gonna get sis was just beat I'm just I'm
totally reacting off I'm just totally
trying all the people that were like no
you don't understand and I guess what I
did the Disney Center like I didn't hate
that you just needed Uncle Ben or
something else there with it oh it's
something they can fix it so I think
like in the know I feel like that movie
series can be really get right in come
on so I'm hoping they put it together
and fix it and it's not just more the
same because that was the big glaring
hole
movie is that I had no idea like why
does some kid who's 15 years old throw
on pajamas and fight crime
that shit's dangerous like you know it's
why do you do that you have to have some
sort of reason I never got anything but
an Tony Stark in me uh I was guessing to
uh part of the movie and I think some
people could say it's probably not a
problem but you have to know a little
bit about spider-man going in Antley
like I didn't all these are spider-man
characters and I followed it fine oh but
I know the spider-man mythos the
original Legend I know the movies you
know a little bit okay no you need to
know Peter Parker so you need to at
least be aware of spider-man I do feel
like we're getting kind of to the point
though where that's like saying well you
need to know Bruce Wayne or Clark Kent I
feel like he may be so much culture yeah
but that's still a valid point thought
you're gonna go in like if I've never
even heard of spider-man it's this good
to see well nobody cuz nobody will have
seen this if they've never heard of
spider-man unless you want them kid yeah
um I think the only thing you need to
know is that there are many iterations
of spider-man out there and this
plunders from all of them that is the
conceit of the movie now you don't need
to know who's spider-gwen is the the
spider-man wark
man if you can't you have pretty good
because they give you an origin that was
the brilliance of it they give you for
origin story this is the most exciting
part of this movie when a comic book is
laid down yeah I was just like yeah life
this movie is it yeah it really really
is I mean down to the lies dentists I
mean every frame you can take a picture
put it in a comic I mean it's a it's
right the closest we've gotten to that
since Sin City where they literally tip
out where they took the frames that had
trampled on the big screen but this one
literally is the line I don't think you
need to know those characters in depth
no but you need to know a little bit
about you know people but you need to
know that that's what they're gonna do
cuz if you really have no idea that
that's even coming you might be like
yeah and if you know that that's oh
they're plundering from all their other
spider-man properties and this is a fun
way to like get them all together if you
know that you're good you don't need to
know them in-depth you're not gonna be I
really don't think you're gonna be lost
yeah if you know the basics like Oh
villain
kingpin Oh Doc Ock oh that's another
thing I thought her review was great
yeah I definitely didn't see that coming
actually she Olivia was like Octavius
was fantastic I thought yeah that's
really menacing oh really on par with
the assignment one's a lot of fun to
agree you're never gonna get the Green
Goblin right I was like I was their last
chance I thought that was supposed to be
the green you don't know cuz I thought I
said something about Goblin - so it's
like yeah he's literally this thing as
elements I don't think it was just be
Hobgoblin but no no no thanks aggregate
well whatever well what are the goblins
I'm just like I give up on that I wash
my hands of this like they're never
gonna get Green Goblin but it was such a
small part of the movie I didn't care a
scorpion was okay the one that Bianca
Liz I thought was especially the musical
score when everybody it was like a
creepy theme it was just like a weird
sound they were about ones and Tails
like yes million times income and then
stay for the very end yeah there's a
great funny thing at the agree I don't
know I got 99 spider-man 2099 something
like that but there's a reference to
that but then they go on top of it it
it's great because you think it's just
gonna be again - let's move to the next
movie and then they just do a great joke
it's amazing this is the first fight I'm
a movie I really really want to see
again and probably will I'm gonna take
my wife to see it yeah and she's gonna
pick him out of my mind she's like
really that's like the best woman look I
know it's got a talking spider pig it's
gonna have to believe me
so there it is I mean I'll be the first
to say I don't think is for everybody I
don't know if it's gonna get the mass
appeal that I feel it deserves but I
think it's gonna be kind of like it
deserves that appeal and the robbing
will get it and that is a hit bucking
shit here's what I think it's gonna be
you know how
we and a lot of people say that mask of
the phantasm is technically the best
band yeah it's not gonna be like that
yeah and people if that be kind of the
movies like well my favorite is
spider-man a lot of people be like oh
before Christmas and Big Lebowski none
of those were popular hits women and now
it's everywhere yeah I feel like the
business story wasn't popular right now
it's too pop I think at the very least
this is gonna get a following I hope so
but you know best-case scenario I hope
into a super well and I hope all of
these characters get movies night really
crap about characters I'm living on is
Hollywood you're supposed to give a shit
I really must see spider Noir so bad Oh
Nicolas Cage hell yeah oh my god
so our spider senses are tingling yeah
so I want to take his face his mouth
does it yes so guy I want to see spider
one to smell I see I'd love to see The
Adventures of penny Parker yeah give me
a spider-man anime though this that's
the other last thing I want to say this
is the closest I mean this is a
spider-man anime the style is very anime
and on top of that animation wise okay I
complained about the low framerate and
we complain about the weird focus trick
they did but this is some of the best
colorful animation unique and use of
magical realism in an anime that I've
seen since Satoshi cone like this
reminded me of paprika perfect blue
millennium actress paranoia agent that
looks like all these things he did where
it's just it's own unique thing and so
bizarre so that's the best compliment I
can give because he's like my favorite
animated director and I'm like it
totally were my I'm like if he made a
superhero movie it would look like this
yeah hands down so um I'm really excited
for more I hope I hope it does well
please go see it so we could get more of
these movies to see them I don't want to
sit through another Adam Sandler film
so guys that's about it and we'll see
you next time take care all right
what was it like that spider pig
spider pig does whatever a spider pig
does yeah we're done
that's his origin story that'd be great
that was the origin story came from The
Simpsons yeah nice
you